are you a worst case scenario type of
person
i definitely am yeah it's a good way to
be
what's the worst case scenario for your
screenwriting career here in los angeles
jay
the worst case scenario would uh
would be that i've done all of this for
nothing that i
never
write anything um
that gets made
or
that gets sold or
that turns into something that
people see
my goal is is to become a professional
screenwriter
that's what i would like to do
and
as long as i can write
and i'm able to
uh um
make that you know
my living i can make a living as a
screenwriter
that's that's
fine but
yeah if i if it just never happens for
me that's worst case scenario i mean i i
can't think of anything
worse than that
you know i've
i've
read stories and and and
seen interviews with people who say that
you know they've written and they've
made money and and nothing's ever
ever been made from what they've written
you know it's like oh i've been
commissioned to write this and you know
rewrite this and
nothing was ever made made a lot of
money but nothing was ever made
in a situation like that
i feel that there's there's there's
always a way to get something made
though
if if
if i'm able to make a living as a
screenwriter but say none of the
projects that i've been working on you
know the studio
or the producer they they decide that
they don't want to make it
i think then i would just try to make
something on my own
i'm still making a living as a
screenwriter
but
at least then i would have i think the
ability
to
then perhaps do something you know on my
own even if it's a short film
you see what i'm saying um because
i'm i'm taking care of myself
i'm i'm earning money
doing what i love to do you know as my
passion and that gives me then the
freedom then to maybe
explore over here to do something else
over here i don't know if that makes
sense but
it does
do you think the words what if
and it you you stayed
in tennessee nothing wrong with
tennessee but or somewhere else maybe
settle down in miami
and never tried
would be worse
oh well
i sure
i i'm i don't mean to put words no no no
no
it's just
like okay
if i'm thinking you know worst case
scenario i mean worst case scenario is
me pursuing
uh
screenwriting and never achieving that
goal never becoming a professional
screenwriter
but me staying in tennessee or new york
or miami just never pursuing it at all
well
there is no worst case scenario in that
scenario because i'm not chasing the
dream
that's how i would look at it sure but
if you still had it inside you would you
just ah the odds are
it won't happen
like if if it's inside me then then i'm
gonna go for it sure you know
that's that's that's with that's with
any any endeavor
that i have like if if it's in me to do
something
believe me i'm gonna i'm gonna chase it
i'm gonna
[Laughter]
what does the 90 year old jay fingers
say
in a conversation
to the j fingers sitting here now
and this 90 year old jay fingers never
pursued screenwriting
never got out of his comfort zone
never risked being alone maybe turning
down
a great night at tgi fridays
what's that conversation like
you know what i i think in that
conversation
the 90 year old jay would
probably be proud
and say at least you you tried
you know you you know you gave it a shot
um
you went out there and and
and you followed your dream
even though that dream perhaps
cost you
everything
at least you tried
uh so yeah i i think that 90 year old
jay would uh
would be proud
okay all right so if we if we're
traveling um ahead in time
and and
he he's like
consoling the jay that's here now or not
even consoling but just giving him
praise for for going for it and keep
going
and
you know i like what you said you said
if if it meant you had to make something
of your own
even if it was a short
that would be okay and then just do
you know polishes or rewrites for other
people
right and that's a lot of people's
careers and i don't think that's a
failure
but everybody has their own bar of what
you know right right what success is
okay
i i
and and just the reason why i mentioned
that is because
i feel like in those interviews that
i've read and seen where people say
you know this is this is you know yeah
i've had a great career but you know
nothing was ever made
i
i don't know i just don't get that i
feel like
the opportunity is there you know
just like i said like a short or or you
know
something you know
it may not be
the big massive
you know 4 000 screens
you know
premiere but but it is something
and then i feel like that's that's why
we get into this business is we want to
create
and tell stories you know especially in
film you know you want people to see
your work so
i feel just feel like the opportunity is
there to create something
that can be seen
what is a chaotic neutral
[Laughter]
um
there's this matrix
that has i guess you know different
personality uh um
traits or whatever
and you've got like lawful good you know
the lawful good person is the person
that you know
will follow you know the letter of the
law and you know they
they're a good nice good person and then
you've got like uh i forget what the the
opposite is it's evil i guess unlawful
evil where you just
whatever so on this matrix
uh i feel i fall in chaotic neutral
right
i'm not a goody two-shoes
but i'm not an evil person
either you know i'm just i'm me i fall
in the middle as far as that goes
as far as chaotic i'm just i'm i feel
like i'm
a bit all over the place you know um
i'm into different things i like
different things i do different things
i sometimes act on spur of the moment
sometimes i will turn down an invitation
for potato skins and cocktails then
sometimes i'll show up
and you you won't expect it like jay
what are you doing here you know so
that's that's
that's kind of what i mean by chaotic
neutral i don't know if that's
really the definition but that's how i
that's how i define it for myself
what would you say is the personality
type of most of the characters you've
created
the protagonists
i would say most of them are a little
little
chaotic
but they would probably fall a little
closer to the good side of the matrix
um
i think most of my protagonists have
good hearts
best intentions for people
i think that most of my characters most
of my protagonists i think they actually
do sacrifice
for
those that they love those that they
care about
um
which makes me wonder if
i'm projecting a little
wish fulfillment on to them just like ah
you know this is this is who i'd like to
be
um
in that respect
but uh yeah most of my characters are
are pretty pretty
good people
yeah
and where is this where did this make
this personality matrix where did this
come from i i don't remem i saw it
online somewhere and you know people
were filling filling out the quiz to get
the uh
the results
and uh i just thought it was funny i
just thought it was funny i was like no
i'm chaotic neutral i already know where
i fall on this spectrum